the opening scene features a widow and
single mother named virginie hebrad let
me try that again Virginia the [__]
virgin
IE hebrad and I hope she's not the main
character she resides in rural France
with her two children Laura and Gaston
ever since her husband's passing
Virginia has been managing his Locust
Farm previously the family used to raise
goats as well but after her husband's
death they shifted their focus to
locusts despite her Relentless efforts
day and night the business doesn't seem
to be performing well lately Virginia
has been struggling to make ends meet as
her locusts are not reproducing like
before and many are dying off one day
Laura takes her younger brother to his
soccer practice where she becomes a
target of bullying this has been a
regular occurrence as all the teenagers
in the city believe that selling locusts
is weird and they're right even Laura
has started disliking her mother for
this meanwhile a customer visits
virgini's Farm interested in buying a
large quantity of locusts I just love
them you see unfortunately Virginia
doesn't have a sufficient quantity in
stock leading the customer to ask for
heavy discounts since Virginia has all
already set a low price she cannot
further reduce it resulting in the
customer canceling the deal I do not
love them that much later in the evening
Virginia takes Laura to help gather some
fresh grass during this time Laura
learns about the canceled deal leaving
her disappointed as the family once
again fails to earn the necessary funds
to meet their daily expenses now that
they are in desperate need of money
Virginia as usual calls her friend
Kareem requesting he lend her some money
in order to make it to the end of the
month generously Kareem agrees and even
contacts someone to ask about the buyers
for Virginia's products meanwhile
Laura's bullies upload a video online
making fun of her mother this finally
begins to take a toll on the teenager
and she starts becoming angrier by the
day elsewhere aboard Gaston takes his
pet Locust out to play but to his
surprise the insect starts feeding on
his wound this reveals that virginie's
locusts are interested in human flesh
and blood as opposed to what milk later
on Virginian or children head to the
city to do some shopping during this
outing Laura spots the same bullies who
had previously posted the offensive
video on social media in response she
goes to confront them and even gets into
a physical altercation with one of the
bullies named Kevin friggin Kevin
unfortunately the guy quickly overpowers
her and ends up striking her in the face
before he can cause any more damage
though virginie intervenes and takes her
children home [__] you Kevin later as
her family reaches home Laura vents her
frustration on her mother she says that
she's fed up living in a house where she
can't even shower without seeing a
locust moreover she is tired of being
the laughing stock in her school where
everyone looks at her like an outcast
after Laura finally calms down virginie
applies ice to her wound and reveals
that she has received an offer for 40
kilograms of locusts how do you weigh
those things she says that although he
is not paying as much as she wants it's
a decent amount adding that if she sells
her lab along with the insects she can
have enough money to move somewhere else
and start a new life hearing all of this
Laura finally becomes happy the next day
the buyer who turns out to be a duck
farmer arrives to buy the insects
however when he sees that they are tiny
and weak he asks for a discount he
rudely tells virginie that he is only
going to pay her 200 Euros instead of
the previously agreed upon 600 as
expected this infuriates the poor woman
and she kicks him off her property then
she storms inside the Locust enclosure
and angrily trashes the nests in the
process virginie trips and knocks
herself out when she comes to her senses
she finds the locusts swarming around
her and feeding on her blood from the
wounds on her arm this sends her into a
momentary Panic prompting her to flee
the enclosure overnight the locusts
become more active and aggressive
creating more noise than ever before the
next day Virginia notices the change and
becomes surprised she speculates that it
could have something to do with the
blood they sucked out of her wound
desperate for a change in circumstances
she partially opens the enclosure
unbandages her arm and inserts her hand
inside her assumption proves correct as
the locusts start devouring her wound
and sucking her blood by night they
become much larger and stronger it's
almost as if they are receiving protein
from the blood
later virginie Dawns her protective suit
to inspect the enclosure shockingly she
notices that the locusts are multiplying
at a rapid rate and laying eggs like
crazy although this is a very unusual
situation virgini decides to take
advantage of it she hires Kareem and
builds a much bigger enclosure to keep
the insects virginie lies to him that
she fed the insects parsley to make them
more active when Laura returns home and
learns about the development she isn't
pleased as she was hoping her mother
would stop the business altogether later
that evening Virginia returns to the
enclosure and provides more of her flesh
and blood from her open wound her
actions are extremely dangerous but she
disregards the potential consequences
and remains focused on selling more
locusts to secure much needed income in
the following morning virginie loads
multiple boxes of locusts and returns to
Briant to make a safe Briand noticing
that the locusts are no fresher and
larger purchases them at a reasonable
price as days pass Virginia's sales
begin to increase the only limitation is
the need to continually Supply them with
blood and flesh since it is impossible
to always feed her blood and flesh
Virginia devises a solution and buys
several liters of blood from a butcher
shop upon delivery she mixes the blood
with flour transforming it into solid
cloths before feeding it to the locusts
on the other hand Laura becomes
increasingly frustrated with her
mother's growing obsession with the
locusts one day she reaches her breaking
point and cannot bear the noise
emanating from the greenhouses any
longer
yes as a result Laura in a fit of anger
tears open one of the greenhouses which
allows a swarm to escape meanwhile
Gaston is nearby in a truck playing with
his goat you get unfortunately the
deadly insects get attracted by the goat
and attack it the poor boy tries his
best to save hugat but the locusts
forcibly take it away
who will I play with so now when
Virginia returns from a trip to town
Gaston tearfully informs her that huget
was taken by the locusts sensing that
something is awry version he instructs
her son to stay inside the house while
she goes in search of fuget not long
after she finds she gets lifeless body
lying in the field covered with hundreds
of locusts feeding on it this devastates
her but she doesn't reveal the truth to
her son instead virginie drives him
around the field pretending that she is
helping him find the pet upon her
turning home version he questions Laura
about the greenhouse tear and the latter
angrily admits her doings this results
in a heated argument between the two
Laura blames her mother for everything
while virginie warns her against
entering the enclosure from today
onwards after several days of Relentless
labor virginie decides to take a day off
and treats her children to a beach
picnic while unwinding by the shore she
also shares her decision to allow Gaston
to attend a soccer school Camp making
him Happy Mama
Jace after enjoying a pleasant time at
the beach the family returns home only
to find Kareem waiting for them with a
new scooter it turns out that the
scooter is a surprise gift from Virginia
to Laura which makes her thrilled mama I
died
yes the same night Virginia and Kareem
have a small chit chat over a cup of
wine their conversation eventually takes
a romantic turn prompting them to kiss
Kareem attempts to proceed further but
Virginia stops him abruptly presumably
because she doesn't want to reveal her
wounds on her body in the next scene we
see Virginia contacting the butcher
requesting an immediate delivery of 50
liters of blood however the seller
declines to engage in further
transactions with her because she has
been purchasing blood without any clear
reason he is also suspicious that she
might be misusing it this leaves
Virginia in a state of worry as she
needs to find a source of fresh blood
ASAP left with no options she again
starts drawing out of her own blood to
feed the insects over time her mental
state begins to deteriorate and she's
starts pushing people away from her
after reaching her physical limit
Virginia starts looking for blood
Elsewhere One night she notices her
neighbor's dog roaming around her farm
and decides to feed it to the insects
however her reign of terror doesn't stop
there she even steals cows from nearby
farms and feeds them to her locusts one
day Laura returns home after dropping
her brother off at soccer camp she calls
out for her mother but receives no
response she then enters her mother's
room and finds the floor covered in
blood-stained clothing alarmed she
rushes towards the enclosure only to
witness a horrifying scene her mother in
her undergarments letting herself be
consumed by the locusts
say this deeply terrifies Laura
prompting her to rush back home and look
at herself in the bathroom I mean lock
herself in the bathroom she immediately
contacts Kareem via text message and
tells him to come to her home because
her mother is unwell not long after
Kareem arrives at the farm where he
finds virginie preparing flour dough for
the locusts he attempts to engage her in
conversation but she continues to ignore
him soon after she suddenly feels dizzy
due to losing a lot of blood believing
that it is because of her work stress
Kareem brings her as well as Laura to
his place and tries to cheer them up
with a movie night we watch a Dracula
yes later while Kareem and Laura are
alone in the kitchen she discloses the
disturbing sight she witnessed on the
farm earlier hearing this Kareem
confronts Virginia
urging her to reveal the truth however
she remains hesitant to divulge what she
has been doing leading to a heated
argument between the two friends
meanwhile the neighbor enters one of the
greenhouses to look for his missing dog
inside he discovers his dog's collar
soaked in blood unfortunate fortunately
before he can react to swarm of locusts
attacks him leading to his death later
on Kareem drops Virginia and Laura off
at their house and after seeing them
entering he begins to look around the
greenhouses before long he comes across
the lifeless body of their elderly
neighbor swarmed by locusts this leaves
him in a state of complete shock moments
later version he finds him outside and
realizes that he's discovered her secret
they again get into an argument and the
crazy woman runs back to her house to
confront Laura she asks the teenager
what she told Kareem but the latter
refuses to talk to her mother and locks
herself inside meanwhile Kareem goes to
his truck and takes out a tank of
gasoline he then douses the greenhouses
completely and lights them on fire after
noticing the commotion version he runs
outside and tries to stop Kareem but he
throws her to the ground just then the
two realize that the locusts have
escaped the enclosure and are gathering
in numbers fearing for his life Kareem
lets virgini go and runs into the house
asking Laura to close all the doors and
windows but but the uh did uh but the
rejected versiony is still adamant on
saving her business she attempts to put
out the fire using the fire extinguisher
however while she hears her daughter
screaming she rushes to the house on the
way she finds poor Karim being eaten by
the damn locusts in the next scene Laura
somehow manages to escape from the house
but she is relentlessly being pursued by
the locusts as she escapes into the
nearby Forest her worried mother also
follows her when Laura realizes that she
has no way out she runs toward a lake
there she notices an overturned boat and
decides to hide under it however the
deadly insects refuse to give up and
start swarming the boat the combined
weight of the locusts start pushing the
boat down and Laura slowly drowns after
a while Virginia finally arrives at the
scene and takes action she bravely cuts
open her Palms with a pocket knife
Morpheus is that you and smears the blue
blood on her face her plan is to attract
the locusts towards her and save her
daughter as expected the plan works and
the insects immediately surround her
virginity then takes the opportunity to
dive inside the lake she goes deep into
the water and holds her breath for a
long time surprisingly the locusts
follow suit and die one after another by
Drowning I don't know if that's what
would have happened there the movie ends
as a version he resurfaces and hugs her
daughter tightly she promises that she
will shut down the Locust business now
she better subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching